November is here and with it comes a
whole horde of amazing games and we're
going to start it all off in a superhot
Subaru with need for speed the upcoming
open world racing game is developed by
ghost games and it's the 21st major
installment in the long-running Need for
Speed series and a full reboot of the
franchise the game boasts a new and
improved customization system and the
chase camera there's five different
gameplay types speed style crew build
and outlaw where players can earn points
for engaging to progress in the game
through five overlapping storylines need
for speed takes place in the fictional
city of ventura Bay and its surroundings
you'll swear look a lot like la go fast
on the third you know what time it is
it's cod blops time the first person
shooter was developed by treyarch for pc
ps4 and xbox one call of duty black ops
3 takes place in a dystopian future set
in 2060 5 40 years after the events of
black ops 2 there are also two confirmed
zombie story lines but you only need to
concern yourself with shadows of evil
because it contains Jeff Goldblum you
could infuse me with time then shoe I
will life finds a way on the six where
there's a triple a movie a lot of times
you'll find a not-so-great video game
we'll see how this one turns out it's
the peanuts movie Snoopy's grand
adventure an upcoming side-scrolling
platformer video game based on the
peanuts movie for nintendo 3ds ps4 wii u
360 and xbox one the player plays as
Snoopy and can also play as woodstock if
you're doing co-op you're trying to look
for Charlie Brown it looks pretty cute
especially when Snoopy dances look at
him I just hope this doesn't follow in
the same footsteps of another certain
sponge out of water video game good
grief youkai watch is a series of
role-playing video games developed and
published by level 5 it was released in
japan in 2013
it's finally making its way to North
America players befriend yokai by giving
them a food they like before beginning
battle and after defeating the yokai it
approaches the player character and
gives them a yokai medal allowing it to
be summoned at will think ghost pokemon
sedum vitam Ketchum battle them catch
them all on the 6th anno 2205 is a city
building an economic simulation game
with RTS elements by Ubisoft 2205 is the
sixth game in the anno series as with
anno 2070 the game is set in the future
with players having the opportunity to
set up colonies on the Moon you take on
the role of a leader from an evil
corporation and must compete against
other evil corporations in developing
future evil technologies good luck join
the future on the 3rd for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and
they're subject to change see you next
week
Oh